SHIP.
HIS COMMANDERS --
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NEVER BEEN
ONE TO MINCE WORDS BUT HE’S
BECOMING PARTICULAR AGGRESSIVE
AS HE CONTINUES TO TRAIL
JOE BIDEN IN THE POLLS.
THE MEDIA IS OF COURSE A
FAVORITE TARGET.
FOX NEWS MEDIA ANALYST AND HOST
OF FOX’S "MEDIA BUZZ"
HOWARD KURTZ TAKES A LOOK.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HASN’T JUST
HAD HIS ADMINISTRATION SUE
JOHN BOLTON HE CALLED THE FORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR A
WACKO, INCOMPETENT, A
DISGRUNTLED BORING FOOL AND A
SICK PUPPY.
>> IN TERMS OF BOLTON, HE BROKE
THE LAW.
HE WAS A WASHED UP GUY AND HE
GAVE HIM A CHANCE.
PRESIDENT HAS ESCALATED HIS
ATTACKS ON ALL KINDS OF
TARGETS ASSAILING THE
SUPREME COURT TO DECISIONS HE
CALLED SHOTGUN BLAST INTO THE
FACE OF REPUBLICANS AND
CONSERVATIVES.
ONE RULING ON GAY RIGHTS WAS
WRITTEN BY NEIL GORSUCH.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THE SEATTLE
MAYOR AND THE THE WASHINGTON
GOVERNOR JAY INSLEE SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS QUOTING
UNNAMED TRUMP ADVISORS IS SAYING
AFTER HE TWEETED "WHEN THE
LOOTING STARTS, THE SHOOTING
STARTS," THAT HIS POLITICAL SELF
SABOTAGE HAS DAMAGED HIS
REELECTION CHANCES AND
QUESTIONING WHETHER HE REALLY
WANTS A SECOND TERM.
2016 AND ALL THE MEDIA
PRODUCTIONS THAT TRUMPS ATTACKS
WOULD DOOM HIM AND THAT’S WHY
SUPPORTERS OFTEN OVERLOOK HIS
HARSHEST RHETORIC.
HE BELIEVES HE CAN PROVE THE
ESTABLISHMENT WRONG AGAIN.
THE PRESIDENT ACCUSED THE FAR
LEFT FAKE NEWS MEDIA OF TRYING
TO COVID SHAME HIM BY FOCUSING
ON THE RISK OF TOMORROW’S
OKLAHOMA RALLY.
TWITTER ITSELF HAS FELT THE THE
PRESIDENTS STING SES ORDER A
REBUKE OF SOCIAL MEDIA FORMS.
TWITTER SLAPPED A WARNING LABEL
ON A TRUMP POST.
THE PRESIDENT IS OFTEN PUNCHING
BAG.
BOLTON’S BOOK DENOUNCES TRUMP AS
UNFIT FOR OFFICE.
CNN’S COVERAGE OF HIM IS LARGELY
NEGATIVE.
THE MEDIA RARELY MENTIONS THE
CORONAVIRUS RISK OF THE RACISM
PROTESTS.
>> I WOULD ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU
TO COVER THE PROTESTS IN THE
SAME WAY THAT YOU COVER THE
RALLY GOERS.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS -- HAD FEW
DEFENDERS WHEN HE WENT AFTER AN
INJURED ELDERLY BUFFALO
PROTESTER BUT IT’S CLEAR HE’S